So today professor ray is not going to be here.
And so we're going to watch two videos and instead one of him and a second one
is a Paul Collier talking a little bit about his book,
but also about recent research that he's done and especially on governance and
commodities.
So,
uh,
we're going to start with the first video and then go straight into the Paul
Collier video.
So enjoy.
Okay.
Yeah.
Hi there.
Um,
as you know,
I'm in Washington today and,
uh,
Jim Alexander has been kind enough to preside over over the Monday class and I
want to get in 20 minutes or so of,
uh,
background thought,
taking us from the Selco case where the question was how to organize the
distribution of distributed electrical generating,
uh,
two bottom billion,
areas of India.
Uh,
from that very specific set of questions to the much larger question about
understanding the plight of the world's bottom billion and the available
strategies for,
uh,
trying to be helpful to them.
Uh,
the main text,
uh,
for these class,
this class.
And the next is Paul Collier's bottom billion,
uh,
which is,
while not a page turning thriller like White Tiger,
uh,
is a very solid,
a serious and substantial a piece of scholarship by somebody who has been
engaged.
Uh,
both with the best of growth economics as a scholar and with the practical work
of the World Bank where he was head of research for a good long time.
Um,
the default assumption in thinking about the bottom billion is to begin with the
world demographic transition.
And the thought that most of these people are the products of stage two and
stage three demographies where birth rates were vastly higher than death rates
and she had a huge surge in population.
And you found,
uh,
and many people in those societies,
found themselves in the same predicament as the protagonist in white tiger as
being one of way too many candidates for every job.
And,
uh,
having little or no market power and consequently little or no,
income.
Uh,
and Colliers take is to,
is to say,
well,
let's just grow incomes and it's not a bad approach.
Um,
and he's perfectly aware of the objections I'm going to make to it,
uh,
in the next few minutes.
Uh,
but let's just catalog what,
what,
what it means.
The,
uh,
gross domestic product is,
at once too broad and too narrow as a measure of value generated by the economy.
Uh,
for example,
uh,
if
a housekeeper and her employer or his,
uh,
marry one another and he or she continues to keep the house,
but now on the basis of spout a spousal relationship,
uh,
the cash goes away and the value is deducted from the GDP.
While in fact,
nothing has much changed.
Or suppose a crime wave hits a society and enormous damage is done to property
by crime.
Uh,
it requires repair.
Those repairs get recorded in GDP and can easily be mistaken for an improvement
in the condition of people living there.
A further,
people buy better locks,
uh,
video cameras,
perhaps even weapons.
And those two are recorded as improvements,
when in fact they really aren't improvements or take disease.
A,
uh,
one society is relatively healthy,
and has relatively lower,
uh,
medical expenses than the other.
Uh,
yet the,
the second,
the one with a high medical expenses would be accounted as better off,
uh,
finally to,
to get the how,
just how mechanical is measure is if for any reason,
uh,
we were,
prepared,
the government say was prepared to pay people to dig holes,
uh,
and then fill them back up with the same dirt and pay him a salary for that.
Uh,
we would,
we would have increased GDP.
So those are ways in which the measure is,
uh,
to inclusive.
Uh,
there are other ways in which it's not inclusive enough.
Um,
uh,
it doesn't include,
you know,
the saying the best things in life are free.
Well,
that may not be entirely true,
but some of the good things in life are free.
And those need to be measured in an accounting of,
of how well office society is.
Uh,
the,
the leading substitute measure these days for GDP per capita is,
uh,
the human development index as put forward by the World Bank and parallel
institutions,
which gives,
uh,
which takes GDP per capita is one part of the story,
adds to it longevity.
Uh,
and then supplements that by adding a measure of education.
So you get a somewhat broader measure that captures the,
the surge we see in Hans Rosling's wonderful data animation as lives become
longer and prosperity greater.
So one thing to do is just tinker with a measure.
A,
there's a second set of issues
that have to do with the value of income.
The,
I've got some childlike drawings here to share with you.
Uh,
if,
if we represent the dollar income of Mr a on the horizontal access and of ms be
on the vertical axis,
uh,
then GDP for these two people is calculated just by adding the one to the other,
with no attention to the distribution between them.
So that all the points on this indifference curve would correspond to the same
GDP as one another.
And all the points on this indifference curve would likewise,
so of correspond.
Well,
that's okay.
There's nothing wrong with that,
except if you want to infer from it the value shared by a and B,
uh,
in the use of that income.
And
the a generally accepted hypothesis is that the value of income and economists
would use the term utility.
Let me just stick with value.
The value of income,
uh,
first increases and then decreases at the margin so that you get an s shaped
curve like this.
On the horizontal axis we have how much income people get,
and on the vertical axis,
how much value they derive from it.
Now imagine down here around point a,
uh,
where people have precious little income,
so little that they cannot feed and clothe and lodge themselves.
Well,
Duh,
I think of a setting like an American city,
and imagine a doubling your income annual income from $25 to $50.
Well,
that would move you a little ways along the horizontal axis,
but it wouldn't really lift you up the vertical axis because it's not going to
make a difference until you get to some threshold where you actually begin to
get increasing returns from a rising incomes,
uh,
as in the zone I've labeled be here.
Uh,
and then eventually at incomes like,
uh,
Richard Medley whom we met a month ago,
or Apollos or Noni,
who we'll meet in a couple of weeks at their incomes.
The,
the,
so wide arrange of material needs are already satisfied
that the marginal dollar gets less and less valuable.
Uh,
the implication of this for the relationship between GDP per capita on the one
side and a judgement of how well a society is doing on the other is that there's
pro,
we should probably,
uh,
have some egalitarian bias in the way we interpret the numbers where most people
get to the level that I'm pointing at here,
where the dimunition of marginal value really sets in where most people get to
that,
uh,
that's kind of where you want to be.
And Colliers,
emphasis on the bottom billion a response to that.
Uh,
and the SELCO project for example,
which we saw,
uh,
a moment saw,
well actually I'm speaking just an hour after class,
which we saw in Wednesday's class,
uh,
is aimed at trying to bring people up that steep part of the curve,
maybe not very far,
but a little ways by judiciously providing the opportunity to purchase a
electric light,
uh,
or electric power for such other purposes as running a sewing machine,
or,
uh,
preparing a goods of some kind for sale.
So the common sense response to this s curve is to pay special attention to
people who are near its bottom and try to find ways to help them push themselves
up the curve.
Now,
as a sidebar,
let me just mention,
uh,
John Rawls,
who published in 1971,
a,
a classic book,
a book that will be read hundreds of years from now,
I imagine a called a theory of justice and Rawls,
Rawls.
Ask people to imagine that they were,
uh,
behind what he called a veil of ignorance.
And the idea of the veil of ignorance is roughly that you have no idea who you
are.
It's a little like Adam Smith's device in a theory of moral sentiments.
But the question is,
if you had no idea who you were,
uh,
before we set up the basic institutions for a country or for the world,
if we think of it on a global scale,
uh,
what,
what would be your way of structuring alternative arrangements so that you could
find one that you thought was best from your,
for your,
for you,
from behind this veil of ignorance and on which you could agree with everyone
else behind the same veil.
And his idea,
um,
stated way to simply is that you should maximize the welfare of the least
advantaged group in society.
The intuition is that that group would be unskilled labor.
And that doesn't mean that you should,
uh,
knock down inequalities necessarily.
Uh,
indeed.
If,
if allowing,
uh,
bankers,
engineers and entrepreneurs,
uh,
to reap substantial,
and very unequal benefits from their work will ultimately read down to the
benefit of this unskilled labor straight up,
uh,
then that's great.
A Rawlsian,
a Rawlsian picture of,
um,
the,
the indifference curves,
which for,
um,
before utilitarianism just run at minus 45 degrees here,
Rawls is our l shaped.
And so if we're here so that this person is way better off than this person,
we tried to move to a higher indifference curve from the point of view of the
less advantaged person and symmetrically here we try to move in this direction
so that the l shaped indifference curves.
If there were just two people in the society would drive us to seek the highest
one and it would have a powerful middle of the road bias to it,
but it wouldn't have so powerful and egalitarian kick that it would knock down
equality to an extent which hurt even the less skilled parts of the workforce,
uh,
societies.
And we know of societies that have reached that level,
uh,
in my judgment,
Castro's Cuba is a just such a case and I know it fairly well.
UH,
North Korea,
which I know much less well,
appears to be such a case.
Okay.
So that's all by way of background.
And now I just want to talk a rather briefly about the,
the introductory series of traps in Collier's book.
And the traps are,
are his way of summarizing things that can go very wrong for a country,
uh,
and put it way behind the rest of the world in economic growth.
Now,
as background,
Collier is really thinking about,
uh,
what we would call emerging market countries.
He's not thinking about Germany,
Japan,
Canada or the states.
He's thinking about,
uh,
India,
Bangladesh,
uh,
Kenya,
Zimbabwe,
Bolivia,
uh,
Mexico,
countries which are
just finishing the world demographic transition and are relatively late entrance
as full players,
uh,
in capitalist development.
Uh,
the majority of them,
uh,
and call your,
gives very little stress to this and you probably should give more.
Uh,
the majority of these countries were colonial sites for a European powers.
And,
uh,
India is just such a case.
For example,
in the British empire was enormous.
Other countries were subject to the Dutch,
the French and,
and other,
and the Spanish in Spanish actually are quite important,
uh,
European powers,
which treated them as,
uh,
um,
subordinate economies and structured their governance to the advantage of the
metropolitan country.
So trap one may,
may be,
um,
be a colonial colonial site and be set back by it.
The other side to that story is that the colonial power sometimes left something
good behind the extraordinary quality of,
uh,
technical education in India,
for example,
uh,
is,
in part a,
an outgrowth of,
uh,
British education and,
the,
the systematic,
uh,
inculcation of a British educational values wouldn't want to go too far
stressing that,
but,
but it's there somewhere.
Okay.
So the,
the Collier traps,
the first one is what he calls a conflict trap.
And,
uh,
according to him,
a 73% of,
uh,
the bottom billion,
live in countries which are now in civil wars or have recently been in civil
wars.
That's a stunning number.
Uh,
and the,
the,
the world which occupies the front page of,
uh,
every major newspaper,
Somalia,
uh,
Iraq.
Uh,
the incredible miss in Afghanistan,
uh,
many other,
less dramatic cases,
uh,
these are all,
countries where civil strife has defined life to,
uh,
to a considerable degree in let's say the last 25 years.
Well,
the call spend some time asking the causes of that.
Uh,
he rejects the,
the common sense popular explanation is ethnic conflict.
And he says that ethnic conflict is actually quite a lot less important than
simple poverty.
That countries with very low GDP per capita,
uh,
are greatly,
greatly at much greater risk of civil war.
Then countries with higher GDP per capita and that countries with growing GDP,
uh,
are more secure than those with static GDP,
particularly particularly static GDP at a low level.
Not much news in that.
Um,
but it's,
it's actually very important because if you think about the logic of capital
development,
capitalist development,
and you take,
uh,
either the Coase theorem or a desotos development of the Coase theorem a
seriously,
which I do.
And,
uh,
and I urge you to,
it's built on the foundation of the Westphalian nation state system,
which came into being in the middle of the 17th century.
And we're civil wars are still in progress.
That system isn't there.
A civil war,
uh,
is indicative of a failed state and a failed state can't perform the
capitalizing functions of government,
which are so central.
The story desoto tells us and about which I think he is,
is,
uh,
very right.
Okay.
Uh,
the,
the
palliatives for this are not obvious.
Uh,
one thing we've pretty much learned is that third party interventions in civil
wars,
uh,
by and large are not a terribly successful.
The second of his traps is,
is the natural resource trap where the,
the standard case would be oil.
Uh,
but it could be,
uh,
any other commodity that is it at great value with and which can be,
harvested and processed and shipped without developing a huge economic
infrastructure,
uh,
or a,
nimbly functioning internal market.
And the,
the gist of this one,
uh,
hinges on what,
what he calls Dutch disease.
And the idea here is that when the Dutch,
uh,
began to export North Sea oil at great profit to their,
to,
to the value of their currency,
uh,
the inflation of,
in the value of the currency made their other export products less and less
competitive and caused a kind of lethargy in the country.
That's,
that's one piece of it.
Um,
it's the,
the other piece which I think is actually more important has to do with the
relationship between a democratic rule and,
uh,
oil or other export products.
And if you'll look carefully at page 43 of Colliers book,
he tells a story which,
which is actually a,
it's a fairly subtle story and,
uh,
and I think it's a true story.
Uh,
and the just of it is that where an economy functions largely by exporting
something like oil,
that the impact of democratic government on the economy is to reduce the rate of
growth.
Uh,
whereas in economies where,
uh,
that form of export production is not important,
a democratic government and the rule of law,
uh,
re relates to an increasing rate of economic growth.
So his slightly smart Alec Term For this is survival of the fattest,
fattest.
Um,
and if you look at the behavior of classic oil states,
uh,
they seem to respond to this.
And once you have an authoritarian government with a,
an oil export economy,
uh,
much of what happens is ugly and a good part of,
the ugliness we see in Russia these days,
for example,
uh,
is made possible,
some might say inevitable,
uh,
by Itch,
powerful export resources in petroleum and natural gas.
Uh,
the landlocked trap.
And here the classic case that will concern us,
we'll be Bolivia where we'll do a,
we'll do a case two weeks from now about trying to re trying to improve water
resources in a major Bolivian city.
Uh,
and being landlocked is a bad thing and it's not hard to capture the intuition
of that because,
uh,
commerce with distant states historically is largely done by marine marine
transportation and absolutely ports of your own.
You depend on ports of other countries,
so that for example,
Switzerland depends on Italian and German porch.
Um,
and uh,
um,
Uganda or Rwanda,
uh,
would depend on Kenyon port.
And,
uh,
it's probably a better idea that to depend on porch systems like those of Italy
or Germany,
then like those of Kenya because there are far more developed.
But there's another side to the story which is that,
uh,
it has call your points out.
Having rich countries for neighbors means you have large markets which don't
require ocean going shipping so that
for example,
Germany and Italy are not just in the way of a exports from Switzerland,
but become markets for those exports and uh,
breed a great deal of wealth.
Indeed.
Call your shows that a 1% increase in GDP per capita in a neighboring state,
uh,
correlates generally with about a 0.4% of an increase in GDP,
in the landlocked country.
We're almost done here.
The last one is bad stage are a really bad for economies.
Uh,
and this one is,
is a no brainer.
Um,
and there are two,
two main ways,
uh,
for states to be bad by being a week,
and unable to enforce the rule of law.
Uh,
tuned in to tonight's,
uh,
six 30 world news.
And I prophesied,
uh,
five days in advance that there will be an account of death and destruction,
in Afghanistan where the Taliban channel challenge,
uh,
the state for control of territory and,
our,
uh,
soldiers,
try to bring a degree of order,
uh,
under almost impossible conditions.
So weak states failed states.
The famous case of Somalia with it's pirates would be another case,
uh,
Iraq after the,
after our intervention was for a period,
a failed state.
And it,
it gives every indication of remaining either a failed state or a,
uh,
well,
why don't I not prophesied about Iraq?
I don't need to have a dog in that fight.
Um,
the other,
uh,
bad government story is kleptocracy.
Um,
and where the government,
where the elite at the top of the government use it as a means for collecting
rent from the rest of society.
Uh,
it is,
uh,
extraordinarily destructive to the economy because it takes away all the
conditions which allow people to make investments and execute business project
and shell product in a sufficiently predictable way to grow the economy.
Um,
the other clip you're about to see is,
um,
Paul Collier himself in a Ted talk explaining,
uh,
no doubt better than I can.
Uh,
what it is that the bottom billion is about.
I look forward to seeing you on Wednesday.
Okay.
So can we dare to be optimistic?
Well,
the thesis of the bottom billion is that a billion people have been stuck living
in economies that have been stagnant for 40 years
and hence the virgin from the rest of mankind.
And so the real question to pose is not can we be optimistic?
It's how can we give credible hope to that billion people?
That to my mind is the fundamental challenge now of development.
What I'm going to offer you is a recipe,
a combination of the two forces that change the world for good,
which is the alliance of compassion and enlightened self interest compassion.
Because a billion people living in societies that have not offered credible hope
is that is the human tragedy,
enlightened self interest.
Because if that economic divergence continues for another 40 years,
combined with social integration globally,
it will build a nightmare for our children.
We need compassion to get ourselves started.
An enlightened self interest to get ourselves serious.
That's the alliance.
The changes the world.
So what does it mean to get serious about providing hope for the bottom billion?
What can we actually do?
Well,
a good guide is to think what did we do last time the rich world got serious
about developing another region of the world that gives us,
turns out quite a good clue,
except you have to go back quite a long time.
The last time the rich world got serious about developing another region was in
the late 1940s
the rich world was you,
America and the region that needed to be developed was my world,
Europe.
That was postwar Europe.
Why did America get serious?
It wasn't just compassion for Europe though.
There was that.
It was,
you knew you had to because in the late 1940 [inaudible] country after country
in central Europe was falling into the Soviet bloc.
And so you knew,
you'd know choice Europe had to be dragged into economic development.
So what did you do last time you got serious?
Well,
yes,
you had a big aid program.
Thank you very much.
That was Marshall Aid.
We need to do it again.
Eight is part of the solution,
but what else did you do?
Well,
you tore up your trade policy and totally reversed it
before the war.
America had been highly protectionist.
After the war.
You Open your markets to Europe,
you drag Europe into the then global economy,
which was your economy,
and you institutionalize that trade liberalization through founding the general
agreement of tariffs and trade.
So total reversal of trade policy.
Did you do anything else?
Yes.
You totally reversed your security policy before the war.
Your security policy had been isolationist after the war.
You tear that up.
You put 100,000 troops in Europe for over 40 years,
so total reversal of security policy.
Anything else?
Yes.
You tear up the 11th commandment,
national sovereignty before the war.
You treated national sovereignty is so sacrosanct that you weren't even willing
to join the League of nations after the war.
You found the United Nations,
you found the Organization for Economic Cooperation and development.
You found the IMF,
you encourage Europe to create.
The European community,
all systems for mutual governance support.
That is still the waterfront of effective policies,
aid,
trade security,
governments.
Of course the details are policy are going to be different because the challenge
is different.
It's not rebuilding Europe,
it's reversing the divergence of the bottom billion so that they actually catch
up.
Is that easier or harder?
We need to be at least as serious as we were there.
Now today aren't going to take just one of those four.
I'm going to take the one that sounds the weakest,
the one that's just motherhood and Apple Pie governance,
mutual systems of support for governance.
And I've got to show you one idea in how we could do something to strengthen
governance.
And I kind of go to share you that that is enormously important.
Now
the opportunity we're going to look to
is,
um,
is a genuine basis for optimism about the bottom billion.
And that is the commodity booms,
the commodity booms,
a pumping unprecedented amounts of money into many.
They're not all of the countries of the bottom billion.
Partly they're pumping money in because commodity prices are high.
But it's not just that.
There's also a range of new discoveries.
Uganda's just discovered oil and about the most disastrous location on earth.
Ghana's discovered oil.
Guinea has got a huge new exploit exploitation of iron all coming out of the
ground.
So mass of new discoveries between them,
these new revenue flows,
dwarf aid.
Just to give you one example,
and Golar alone is getting $50 billion a year in oil revenue.
The entire aid flows to the 60 countries of the bottom billion last year with 34
billion.
So the,
the flow of resources from the commodity booms to the bottom billion or without
precedent.
So there's the optimism.
The question is how is it going to help their development?
It's a huge opportunity for transformational development.
Will it be taken?
So here comes a bit of science and this is a bit of science I've done since the
bottom billions.
So it's new.
I've looked to see what is the relationship between higher commodity prices of
exports and the growth of commodity exporting countries.
And I've looked globally,
I've taken all the countries in the world for the last 40 years and look to see
what the relationship is and the the short run.
So the first five to seven years is just great.
In fact,
it's Hunky Dory.
Everything goes up,
you get more money cause you terms of trade to improve.
But also that drives up output across the board.
So GDP goes up a lot.
Fantastic.
That's the short run.
And how about the long run come back 15 years later?
Well the short run,
it's Hunky Dory,
but the long run,
it's Humpty dumpty.
You go up in the short run.
But then most societies historically have ended up worse than if they'd had no
blooms at all.
That is not a forecast about how commodity prices go.
It's a forecast of the consequences,
the longterm consequences for growth of an increase in prices.
So what goes wrong?
Why is there this resource curse as it's called?
And again,
I've looked at that and it turns out that the critical issue is the level of
governance,
the initial level of economic governance when there is all spoons accrued.
In fact,
if you've got good enough governance,
there is no resource.
Boom.
You go up in the short term and then you go up even more in the long term.
That's Norway,
the richest country in Europe,
it's Australia,
it's Canada.
The resource curse is entirely confined to countries below a threshold of
governance.
They still go up in the short run.
That's what we're seeing across the bottom billion at the moment,
the best growth rates they've had
ever.
The question is whether the short run will persist.
Okay
with bad governance,
historically over the last 40 years,
it hasn't.
It's countries like Nigeria,
which are worse off than if they'd never had oil.
So
there's a threshold level above which you go up in the longterm below which you
go down just to benchmark that threshold.
It's about the governance level of Portugal in the mid 1980s
so the question is at the bottom billion above or below that threshold.
Now there's one big change since the commodity booms of knife and seventies and
that is the spread of democracy.
So I thought,
well,
maybe that is the thing which is transformed governance in the bottom billion.
Maybe we can be more optimistic because of the spread of democracy,
so I looked,
democracy does have significant defects and unfortunately there are adverse
democracies make even more of a mess of these resorts spoons.
Then autocracies at that stage,
I just wanted to abandon the research,
but
it turns out that democracy is a little bit more complicated than that because
sort of two distinct aspects of democracy is electoral competition,
which determines how you acquire power and the checks and balances which
determine how you use power.
It turns out that electoral competition is the thing that's doing the damage
with democracy where a strong checks and balances make resources becomes good,
and so what the countries are,
the bottom billion need is very strong checks and balances.
They haven't got them.
They got instant democracy in the 1990s elections without checks and balances.
How can we help improve governments and introduce checks and balances in all of
the societies of the bottom billion that are intense struggles to do?
Just that.
The simple proposal is that we should have some international standards which
will be voluntary,
but which would spell out the key decision points
that need to be taken in order for it to harness these resource revenues.
We know these international standards work because we've already got one.
It's called the extractive industries transparency initiative.
That hell is the very simple idea that governments should report to their
citizens what revenues they have.
No sooner was it proposed then reformers in Nigeria or adopted it,
pushed it and published the revenues in the paper.
Nigerian newspaper circulation spiked.
People wanted to know what their government was getting in terms of revenue so
we know it works.
What would the content be of these international standards?
I can't go through all of them,
but I'll give you an example.
The first is how to take the resources out of the ground.
The economic process is taking the resources out of the ground and putting
assets on top of the ground and the first step in that is selling the rights to
resource extraction.
You now how rights resource extraction of being sold at the moment,
how they've been so level of us.
40 years a company flies in,
does a deal with a minister and that's great for the company and it's quite
often great for the minister and it's not great for the country.
There's a very simple institutional technology which can transform that and it's
called very fine auctions.
The
the public agency with the greatest expertise on earth is of course the treasury
that is the British Treasury and the British Treasury decided that it would sell
the rights to third generation mobile phones by working out what those rights
were worth.
It worked out.
We were worth 2 billion pounds just in time.
Instead of economists got there and said,
why not try an auction,
it'll reveal the value.
It went for 20 billion pounds through auction.
If the British Treasury can be out by a factor of 10 think what the Ministry of
Finance in Sierra Leone is going to be like.
When I put that to the president of Sierra Leone,
the next day he asked the World Bank to send the team to give expertise on how
to conduct auctions.
There were five such decision points.
Each one needs an international standard.
If we could do it,
we would change the world.
We would be helping the reformers in these societies who are struggling for
change.
That our modest role,
we cannot change these societies,
but we can help the people in these societies who are struggling and usually
failing because the odds are so stacked against them
and yet we've not bought these rewards.
If you think about it,
the cost of promulgating international rules is Zilch.
Nothing.
Why on earth are they not there?
I realized that the reason they're not there is that until we have a critical
mass of informed citizens in our own societies,
politicians will get away with gestures tha tha tha unless we have an informed
society.
What politicians do,
especially in relation to Africa,
is gestures,
things that look good but don't work.
And so I realized we had to go through the business of building an informed
citizenry.
That's why I broke all the professional rules of conduct for an economist,
and I wrote an economics book that you could read on a beach.
However,
I have to say the process of communication does not come naturally to me.
This is why I'm on this stage,
but it's alarming.
I grew up in a culture of self effacement.
Um,
my wife showed me,
uh,
a blog comment on one of my last talks and the blog comment said,
Kalia is not charismatic.
Okay.
That his arguments are compelling.
If [inaudible]
if you agree with that sentiment and if you agree that we need a critical mass
of informed citizenry,
you will realize that I need you.
Please become ambassadors.
Thank you.
[inaudible]
okay,
Professor Ray will be back on Wednesday and I will see you then.